il se joue là dans le bruit des maisons
qui craquent une question essentielle
comment protéger les citoyens et
citoyennes face à l'amplification du
réchauffement climatique la semaine
dernière durant la niche parlementaire
écologiste l'Assemblée a voté le texte
de Sandrine Rousseau pour mieux protéger
les Français face au risque du retrait
gonflement d'argile d'hier Géa derrière
ce terme un peu technique se cache des
dégâts qui menacent potentiellement plus
de 10 millions de maisons dans le pays
le retrait gonflement d'argile c'est le
mouvement des sols constitué d'argile
c'est-à-dire 48% de l'Hexagone ce
phénomène il est accentué par les
changements brutaux de météo en cas de
forte pluie le sol se gorge en eau et
gonfle puis il serait assèche avec la
chaleur et provoque un mouvement de
terrain conséquentie médiate les maisons
se fissurent voir s'effondre 3 cm
et parfois plus quoi
de l'intérieur je vois le jour et le
dérèglement climatique ne devrait pas
arranger les choses dans ce texte donc
trois axes principaux pour accompagner
les victimes inscrire dans la loi une
méthodologie adaptée pour reconnaître
l'état de catastrophe naturelle un
statut indispensable pour que les
assurances rembourse particulier les
dégâts et la reconnaissance de ce statut
elle va être simplifiée maintenant il
faudra que l'année concernée soit l'une
des cinq plus sèches des 50 dernières
années contre deux sur 50 ans auparavant
le texte voté prévoit enfin que les
indemnités versées par les assureurs
puissent être utilisés pour acheter un
nouveau bien immobilier pas juste pour
le rénover